Juneteenth it's a holiday often called
the black fourth of July it's celebrated
with cookouts festivals historical
reenactments and it's one of the most
important days in african-american
history
Juneteenth celebrates the end of slavery
in the United States you see the US
Declaration of Independence data that
all men were created equal but this
didn't apply to black slaves the move to
end slavery didn't happen until Abraham
Lincoln issued a law in 1863 almost 100
years later but the news took more than
two years to reach all parts of the
country the state of Texas was the last
to find out On June 19 1865 250,000
slaves were freed in Texas marking
independence for all Americans
you